yeah hello and welcome to this video  which is the announcement form in the  live shows for this week and there on  Tuesday on today because Wednesday is  occupied by them Grantchester in Paris  yeah the Blitz part and yeah we don't  want to really compete with that so the  Tuesday is a good day today there is no  round as a rest day so I'll be on  tonight and it starts at 7:00 p.m.  Central Europe in time for the German  show and then at 8:30 we are here for  the been to blitz the English language  show so make sure to join I think it's  good that we change this as there is no  conflict and down I mean the Blitz gran  Chester's days are always good to watch  in particular they've got Peter Spallone  commentating so something to look  forward to tomorrow I hope you will make  it today and yeah three hours of mental  chess if you do watch both language  versions thanks for watching the  announcement see you later today